[Applause]
thank you
we are working we are doing all this to
to keep the people happy and proud of
the countries
I think we needed this long period
without the pressure that we feel here I
think all the players are ready
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm confident that the players will give
their best in all three matches and that
we will go through we will give a
performance that will be up to the level
of the organization of this world cup
and we will make our country proud
foreign
[Music]
we know that we are facing pretty very
top national teams very strong to play
at home we hope that he's going to give
us some extra with the help of the
people to to try to do well and compete
at our highest level
[Applause]